The reason you cannot trust the Bible is because it advocates slavery.
Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Time out. The second greatest miracle of the Old Testament was what?
The exodus. What's happening in the Exodus?
God is delivering the Hebrew slaves from slavery in Egypt.
But there was slavery that was recorded in the Bible.
Yes, that's right.
There's slavery.
That's recorded.
There's polygamy,
that's recorded.
There's rape, that's court recorded.
There's murder.
That's recorded.
Never is the Bible saying these are good.
Rather, the Bible is helping people living in a corrupt,
depraved culture learn how to deal with it.
Exodus, Chapter 21,
verse 16. It says very clearly,
if you kidnap someone and are caught with them in your possession
or having gotten rid of them and sold them,
you must be put to death.
You kidnap somebody
and you're caught with them in your possession as your slave,
or you've sold them to somebody else,
you ought to be put to death.
When you get to the New Testament,
you're in the Roman Empire,
and over 50% of the people in the Roman Empire were slaves.
Doctors were slaves,
lawyers were slaves,
business people were slaves.
It was like indentured servants.
Were some of those slaves mistreated?
Tragically, yes.
A lot of those slaves, though,
were treated very respectfully.
Now, when Paul says,
slaves, obey your masters,
what he's doing is he's not saying that slavery is good,
but he is saying Christians do not follow Spartacus.
And cause a slave rebellion in the Roman Empire?
Because that's really gonna mess things up.
Instead, respect yours masters.
Understand that freedom is best.
And when you study the abolition of slavery around the world,
usually it is motivated by followers of Christ,
like Frederick Douglas here in the United States,
who understood, biblically,
all human beings are created in the image of god.
Therefore, to enslave someone is absolutely evil.
They fought against slavery,
for the abolition of slavery,
and they succeeded,
because Jesus Christ and the Bible teach that no man,
no woman, is inferior to anybody else,
because god created all of us in his image.